err thank you for coming by you're
welcome so as we sit here in May of 2003
what do you think is the number one
problem facing this country right now
lack of civic motivation to break
through make a country in the world
better there's too many people have
given up on themselves that they don't
believe they have any power that they
may can make a difference they can count
or and of course the people who haven't
given up in themselves throughout
American history of shown how much can
be done well I have those who've given
up given up partly because the way we
grow up we grow up looking at the
country through corporate eyes and we
don't have civic skills in our schools
we don't learn Civic skills who don't
learn how to practice democracy and
partly because the choices are too
narrow you have to to parties and
converging with one another Republican
Democrat the similarities between them
tower over the dwindling real
differences that they're willing to
fight over and people don't have enough
of a choice we need third parties fourth
parties we need more vigorous
presidential debates not a debate
Commission it is a private company
controlled by the two parties to exclude
other viewpoints Ralph Nader will be
here for the full hour and we'll split
the phone lines this way if you support
President Bush's policy called 2025 853
880 if you oppose the president's
policies 2025 853 881 and the
international line 202 5853 883 our
guest is public advocate Ralph Nader who
ran for president in 2000 as the green
party candidate what percentage of the
vote did you get about three percent
what do you think your effect on that
race was well I think we opposed the
overriding issue of corporate control
over our government and our elections
and the commercialism of our society and
under that umbrella we pointed out one
out of every three workers it doesn't
get a living wage that's 47 million
full-time workers in the country we
pointed out the chronic poverty that our
economic system doesn't seem to be able
to address pointed out environmental
devastation dirty elections the whole
commercialization of elections point out
the need to crack down on corporate
I'm Fraud and Abuse i think we predicted
quite accurately that there is a
burgeoning corporate crime wave in this
country that's already drained trillions
of dollars millions of workers including
their jobs and pension funds so you can
see how these are a lot of the issues
that the democrats if they were the old
democrats should have addressed but when
they're taking money from the same
commercial interest as the republicans
they tend to turn their back on these
issues that affect everyday people are
you going to run again too early to say
too early to say you've authored this
book crashing the party taking on the
corporate government in the age of
surrender when did the book come out
came out in 2001 and this is the
paperback updated let's go to Durham
North Carolina Iran with Ralph Nader
hello good morning good morning how you
been fine good hi mr. Nader taking my
call thank you thank you to see span for
having this public forum appreciate it
my question is is it seems as though the
corporatization of government has been
taking place for a number of years the
latest example seems to be the the
corporate protections for vaccine
manufacturers and their immunity from
suit for children that have been injured
by vaccines and I'm wondering if you've
been following any of the debate many of
the proposals that are coming from the
Senate help committee for Senator first
proposal center around the protection of
the corporations rather than protections
of the children I'm wondering if you
might comment on this place and thank
you for taking my call thank you it's
all part of the drive for immunity by
corporations you know 200 years ago
corporations started out with limited
liability for their investors now they
want a limited liability or immunity for
the corporations and the vaccine example
is one I mean President Bush campaigned
in year two thousand on the theme of
responsibility that behavior should have
consequences but he didn't include
corporations under that rubric right now
in Congress there are all kinds of bills
to give immunity to the gun
manufacturers to give limited liability
to physician practices and hospitals
under Medicaid
to give limited liability and tie the
hands of judges and jurors in the state
courts the only people who hear seen
evaluate the evidence by limiting what
injured people can get in a court of law
on product defects as well so it's
really a diminishing of the roles of
judiciary no one ever asked the state
judges they think there's a crisis and
they think they need to be federally
preempted and people should get the
facts on this the citizen org click on
Congress watch will give you a lot of
that and center JD org will give you
more because this is one of the pillars
of our democracy Paul the civil justice
system then you have civil liberties and
you have civil rights what do you make
of the way the government's responded to
Enron to worldcom all of those big
scandals we've been reading about well
they just apart is prosecuting enron and
worldcom but the point is is never
pointed out is that there are probably
about 70 attorneys and the Justice
Department dealing with the corporate
crime wave and most of them are taken up
by four cases Tyco enron worldcom
adelphia maybe help south now and all
that mr. Bush says about dealing with
corporate crime he doesn't talk that
much about it because a lot of these
corporate criminals are contributors to
the Republican Party and some of them
are his friends in Texas and elsewhere
doesn't mean anything if you don't beef
up the prosecutorial corps in the
Justice Department more FBI agents
investigating more lawyers hired you can
double the SEC budget but the SEC
doesn't prosecute they send it over to
the Justice Department so I really
calling on Congress to pay some
attention to the budget of the corporate
crime core inside the Justice
environment and enlarger because
trillions of dollars from millions of
workers a lot of money we go to buffalo
new york for ralph nader welcome mr.
Nader thank you very much I have a
couple questions and i hope you allow me
a follow-up response to your answer i
wanted to ask you about if you intend to
have another run for the presidency but
in light of your first caller I really
want to ask you you've always been out
front leaning
the pack speaking out in support of coop
consumer rights and protection and we
really look to you for your leadership
to help keep corporations honest and
their products ace will use sir step
forward and do what no other public
consumer rights advocate has done and
exposed in a very public way the
conflicts of interest and criminal
conduct done by the FDA the CDC and the
pharmaceutical industry that continues
to this day to poison American children
and what would be the appropriate
consequences for a member of Congress
who continues to lie to the public
putting more children at risk when they
tell them there is no longer mercury in
vaccines when in fact children are given
warmer treat today via their vaccines
than ever before in history thank you
ralph nader because that was a proposal
to eliminate the lawsuits that parents
have been filing on behalf of their
children in Congress that hasn't come
through yet understand the caller's from
Buffalo we just had a big rally in
Buffalo canisius college democracy
rising org for details on that but it
dealt with consumer groups and there is
a conflict of interest for example a lot
of the medical devices that the FDA
supposed to approve or reject are now
not tested by the FDA they're tested in
private laboratories who also do
business for the medical device
manufacturers a lot of the advisory
committees to the FDA are similarly
conflicted conflict of interest is a
huge problem in the private corporate
sector and in terms of the government as
well a lot of the advisory committees to
the Pentagon Department interior part of
Agriculture and all they're all
completely conflicted in terms of their
own private commercial interests or
their own clients Fayetteville Arkansas
good morning good morning mr. Nader I
was curious to hear your thoughts on the
recent anti-war protest I was wondering
what you thought was most successful
about them what were some of the
problems and how did the media affect
their perception it seems like if there
were a thousand protesters somewhere and
four of them got naked or something like
that those four would get all the press
so I was just curious to hear your
thoughts on that whole recent thing
being with you can with your take on the
war itself you know
that's an interesting for you know at
one demonstration there were 500 towns
and cities that had demonstrations it's
really quite extraordinary in large part
because of the vigor of the leaders of
these demonstrations and the Internet in
five months the anti war effort grew to
a level that took five years during the
Vietnam period but I think with the
cheerleading of too many in the media
and the lack of outspoken is by
Democratic Party it was left to the
American people who disagreed with this
war and who thought that it was
unconstitutional clearly it was Congress
did not declare war surrendered is warm
making power of article 1 section 8 to
the White House and the sidestepping of
the UN and their weapons inspectors and
the ability that President Bush could
have exercised in dealing with this
problem by an expansion of international
law rather than an unilateral move all
of this was publicized because of these
demonstrations what about post-war Iraq
what should be happening now well you
know I said months ago that it's a lot
easier to get into Iraq than it is to
get out of Iraq and that's occurring now
what's interesting is the main reasons
President Bush gave to go into Iraq that
Saddam Hussein had chemical biological
radio no clear weapon in preparation
that's been shown to be not true the
weapons inspectors have had over a month
and controlled the country they can't
find a thing that Washington Post
reports today they're about to go back
home the other thing was that he was a
threat to the United States and even the
CIA and the State Department didn't
believe that now you can see how weak
his military was and the third is he was
tied in with al-qaeda and September 11th
and President Bush deliberately mislead
the American people on that and seventy
percent of the american people believed
that that was the case the tie with 911
and that was a great part of the support
for invading iraq by the american people
based on a false inaccurate statement so
you know the only rationale left was to
liberate the Iraqi people from a brutal
dictator and that remains to be seen how
much they're going to be
operated there's all kinds of chaos
anarchy pillage plunder destruction
disease sickness disintegration of the
society and let's see if we're as good a
colonial power as we are military power
we go to the international line for
Ralph Nader to Dubai in the United Arab
Emirates welcome to the program thank
you for taking my call mr. Nader a
question for you I did not vote for you
just for your information but I wanted
to know when mr. Nader runs for an
office one do you think you're really
going to win or you run for bringing
issues that other parties in bring to
the table and finally I wanted to know
your uh your take on that pit on the
edge attacks first of all the Patriot
Act is an enormous slander and
laceration of our civil liberties is
vastly exaggerated piece of legislation
even Jim Gilmore the former conservative
Republican governor of Virginia who now
heads the Gilmore task force for
President Bush on terrorism policy came
out a couple days ago severely
criticizing the patriot act as an
infringement of our freedom as tipping
the balance against our civil liberties
far too much in favor of alleged dealing
with security issues you know Ben
Franklin once said those who trade their
freedom for security deserve neither and
the idea of being able to search your
home in your business without telling
you breach confidentiality of grand jury
proceedings get into your medical
records your financial records your
genetic records your library borrowings
and so on that's about as unamerican as
I can see and if John Ashcroft and Bush
are going to put Patriot to before the
Congress I hope the American people were
really rise up here and and not only
block it about stop the Patriot Act from
being renewed and a year or two caller
asked why you ran for president yes well
one is to build a process in our country
we have a winner-take-all system we
don't have you know proportional
representation way they have in Europe
where if you get five percent of the
vote and you
I mean you get five percent of the
Parliament and so one cycle is not going
to do it but you have to start somewhere
to give people a broader choice than the
two parties are affording second you
raise the issues as I mentioned earlier
raised all these issues universal health
care for example living wage the need to
have public funding of public elections
those things are not raised normally
except in a political context and let's
face it citizen groups have been
increasingly blocked out of the city in
Washington because there are now dollar
signs on almost every door and it's only
in the political arena that the press
will pay the slightest attention we used
to have hearings in Washington public
congressional hearings petitions of for
agencies and now regardless of whether
the Democrats Republicans are empower
the big businesses control one major
department agency after another and
they're blocking out the citizens of
this country from participating in their
government moving on to Houston for
Ralph Nader hello yes my name is Alice
and I live down in the southeast sears
County which is the petrochemical area
of the world I guess you might say I
might say also that I have been a
Republican all my life up until Bush ran
for a second governorship I did vote for
him the first time and did not vote for
him the second time because I was had
gotten involved with the pollution issue
here in this area and the way permits
are put out to the big corporations in
the petrochemical plants in this area
found frightening things in his
administration basically he was didn't
say I am for the citizens I want to
reduce pollution but yet when it came to
funding the actual policing of these
violations and that type of thing there
wasn't any money to do that you put the
polluters in charge of his pollution
regulatory agency as well so a member of
teak happen as you said civic duty I
never got involved until an incident
that happened near my home and then once
you start really checking in to what's
happening one of the frightening things
that I
I went once too often for a protest and
found out the governor had made a
special protest area which was not you
were not even allowed to protest on the
sidewalk in from the governor's mansion
that was prompted by a protest by people
in wheelchairs and then they decided
that didn't look good so what they did
was they made a protest Syria which was
basically the back of a parking lot
thanks Susan she's describing what the
Democrats failed to do is make governor
Bush's record in Texas a major campaign
issue he heard two thousand it was left
up to Molly Ivins and Jim Hightower to
do that she points out a very important
thing toxic chemicals that produce
cancer don't discriminate between
Republicans Democrats or liberal lungs
or conservative lungs and the ability in
have flicked silac human of violence on
tens of thousands of workers and people
in that hot spot that she was talking
about should challenge the rule of law
and there should be a crackdown you know
the styles of violence that the
oligarchy ignores in this country 3,000
people were killed or massacred in
September 11th and since September 11
300,000 Americans have died from
preventable causes just in three areas
medical malpractice air pollution and
occupational disease and trauma now the
key is preventability some of the deaths
are intentional and some of the deaths
are not intentional in all these areas
that the key is preventability that's
what should spark our car conscience and
the way to deal with all politicians
Paul this I learned that my father
mother's new years ago is to separate
their words from their deeds so one of
those president candidate says leave no
child behind I'm a compassionate
conservative you say well let's see what
you did in contrast to what you said
unless people are acutely aware of
separating the word from the deed the
record from the rhetoric they're going
to be subjected to easy manipulation by
clever 30-second television ads during
during campaigns after two-plus years in
office what would you give
Bush credit for what has he done well
well he's maintained some of the things
that the government has been doing well
all these years I mean there's certain
level of activity that the government
does well I mean you know they clean up
the parks once in a wild they they have
social services the social security
checks are delivered but I think he's
done enormous damage to our democracy
never mind to just favoring the wealthy
over working families in this country
the idea of a tax to major tax cuts for
the wealthy I mean anything to do with
economic activity it's absolutely absurd
the issue here is not the lack of
capital to invest there's plenty of
unused capacity in our economy the issue
is consumer demand and you get consumer
demand by raising the minimum wage to at
least the purchasing power level it was
in 1968 the federal minimum wage now is
five dollars and fifteen cents if was
indexed since nineteen sixty eight the
way congressional salaries are it would
be almost eight dollars an hour and
that's more purchasing power so there
it's just completely back ended and
unless people really become alert to how
look they've lost control of their own
government it's the extent to which
corporations and their allies in
Washington have taken control we're just
going to get America being kept down
again and again again and most of the
people being losers economically
socially and politically moving on a
shingle springs california hello
California shingle springs california
you're there I think we lost them let's
go to bedford texas hello fine i would
like to ask mr. Nader please would be
what do you feel is is the worst of the
bush egregious actions that he's taken I
mean it's I mean there's so many as hard
to choose but what you feel is the worst
and just a comment you mentioned the
Patriot Act two earlier Congress is
already trying to slip stuff on that
into other bills you check out Senate
bill eight Senate bill 16 they're taking
sections of Patriot Act two and trying
to put them in because of the the outcry
that came out just because of the
potential news about it so yes so much
well on patriot to that the whole draft
bill is on
center for public integrity org website
I think the worst thing President Bush
has done is severely damaged our already
weakened democracy the Patriot Act and
the attack on American Civil Liberties
is one the packing of the courts with
ideological right-wingers that aren't
going to give a fair shake to consumers
as they are prone to to corporations
when there's a court case is to the
horrendous shift the budgets into the
military half of the federal
government's discretionary spending now
is military at the expense of all of
these areas where Americans are feeling
cuts now you know tuition has to go up
education Scott health care for children
escot infant nutrition is caught public
transit everything's cut so we can have
more and more weapon systems designed
for a Soviet Union era of hostility
weapon systems condemned by retired
Admirals and generals repeatedly at the
Center for Defense Information CD Iorg
org and so he's severely damaged the the
budget and he's throwing the country
into a massive deficit it may reach four
to five hundred billion dollars this
year and that means that we're seeing
inflation and higher interest rates and
even greater debt of the United States
abroad with a potential weakening of the
dollar and if the Japanese Germans and
others pull the plug on our treasury
bond on their Treasury bond investments
we're going to be in serious trouble so
I think he's done a lot of damage to the
country but the Democrats have allowed a
lot of this to occur by not vigorously
fighting in Congress and not at least
retaining the Senate which they blew in
the year 2000 2002 Overland Park Kansas
for Ralph Nader thanks for winning yes
good morning morning my question has to
do with the president's father he lives
in Houston and that's a high
concentration for pollution and I was
wondering if if if we opened up more oil
in areas where it's colder than
say Texas would that cut down on
pollution and another question is why
did co2 emissions increase during the
90s so much but then pollution is
actually going down because we've had
higher energy prices Thanks well I don't
think pollution is a function of
temperature although it seems that way I
mean if you got a petrochemical plant in
Northern California you're going to get
a lot of pollution if it's the same kind
of petrochemical line co2 has been going
up because you know the world is burning
more coal is burning more greenhouse
gases and what we need is solar energy
you know there's enough solar energy
examples in our country when power
photovoltaics solar thermal that they've
proved themselves solar energy has been
around for over 2,000 years passive
solar architecture the ancient Greeks
and Persians and East Africans but it's
now confronting us with a great
potential worldwide we could become the
leaders and solar energy but not not as
long as oil gas and coal companies got
their hooks into Washington DC and are
grabbing off so many taxpayer subsidies
along with nuclear power I mean most
people don't realize how many dollars of
their tax dollars are going directly
indirectly into those industries with
the solar industry fledging as it is
being short changed into trying to
compete on an on level playing field but
a half-hour left with Public Advocate
and presidential candidate from 2000
Ralph Nader who's written this book
crashing the party mr. Nader what will
the 2004 presidential election be about
if he could pick one topic what's it
going to be about that's going to be
about George Bush I suppose and his
policies but the question is whether the
Democrats are going to just run on
certain policies and not take on george
bush or whether they're going to make
George Bush the centerpiece of their
criticism of Washington policy who do
you suspect is the strongest Democratic
candidate of all of the names out there
right now it's very hard to say really
is very hard to say I mean you can say
who the front
runners are just because they have more
money and they show up in the polls
Kerry and gov art and Graham and Edwards
and a number of others but it means very
hard to say and as you know Iowa and New
Hampshire are going to be not decisive
but they're going to shake out the field
a little bit Bedford England for Ralph
Nader hello hi Ralph Nader hello head
please yes my question to you it's
several fold one is a reference to the
Iraq war when an American president lies
about the motives for going to war like
they did in this war why is it no
reflective now in the polls in terms of
what Americans think about the president
the other issue is in reference to you
why are we not seeing you more often
about arguing about this telling us
about these issues and make any clear to
American people because it may not be
obvious to them that the president has
lied to them in reference to go into war
with Iraq thank you yes well you know
the difference between being being
engaged in false statements or lion lion
is a state of mind but when so many of
these false statements were declared to
be false before the invasion of Iraq by
the president's own advisers for example
the CIA and FBI told the White House
repeatedly it is no connection between
Saddam Hussein 911 and al-qaeda actually
they're mortal enemies between the two
and so is it a false statement is a
deliberate lie I guess only the
historians will be able to ferret that
out but this this the caller is it makes
an interesting point why hasn't the
polls on President Bush dropped its
dropping on economic issues but not on
the war no I guess because victory
always camouflages all these things and
nobody that doubted that there is going
to not going to be victory over a
weakened military in Iraq with
antiquated equipment with soldiers you
don't want to
I for their dictator but it's an
important point as to whether the
American people take umbrage at being
persuaded to support the President on so
many false statements including chemical
biological warfare weapons you know
about eight weeks ago or nine weeks ago
President Bush on his Saturday rod cast
station announced that his intelligence
informed him that Saddam Hussein has
given his field commanders the authority
to use chemical and biological warfare
and I mean at what point do all these
intelligence alerts yellow alert this
alert nothing happens at what point do
we begin to ask are these guys really
getting semi reliable information for
the 30 billion dollars we're spending on
intelligence agencies are they erring on
the side of total caution so they get
any kind of rumor out of some person in
Guantanamo Bay that they alert all the
banks that something's going to happen
after a while when you call cry wolf too
often people are not going to be
listening so what do you make of all the
talk about these other countries Syria
Iran North Korea and how the US should
handle those situations well I'm a firm
believer in handling pneus through
multilateral approach through the United
Nations whenever possible through allies
we're already seen as a super hyper
superpower throwing our weight around
the world and you know we're a very
powerful military but we're also very
vulnerable in our country as the news
media points out again and again
chemical plants and our seen gas and
chlorine tanks and subways and so forth
so we have to be very careful in
realizing although we have weapons that
can blow up the world two hundred times
over and make the rubble bouts that
we're extremely vulnerable to what's
called asymmetric warfare in the CIA
which is this kind of guerilla terrorist
warfare so it's much better if we not
only put our best foot forward in the
world by announcing a massive assault on
global infectious diseases for example
which will get us a lot of goodwill
especially since many of these diseases
are coming toward this country and
drug-resistant fashion malaria TV of
course aids but also when we want to
move on
and regimes that we think are threats
international peace that we do that
through the United Nations and
strengthen the United Nations we're main
factor maybe we should pay our dues on
time as well Santa Rosa California Iran
with Ralph Nader good morning good
morning Paul good morning Ralph morning
question earlier in the program you
stated that it's been 30 days that our
inspectors have been in Iraq looking for
weapons of mass destruction and haven't
found them I'd like to point out that
during those same 30 days we've been
looking for Saddam Hussein and his two
sons and we haven't been able to find
them either does that suggest to you
that they were never there either or is
it possible that maybe the biological
and chemical weapons left the country
the same time they did well that's
always was a risk the critics of the war
inside the Bush administration and there
were many dissenters in the Pentagon and
CIA and State Department at sub-cabinet
levels against this kind of war thought
that one of the things that would occur
after toppling Saddam Hussein was it
would be a dispersal of chemical
biological weapons or precursors and a
lot of cash outside the country in
terrorist stateless terrorist circles
and you your point reminds one that that
might actually have occurred we don't
know to present time Baltimore good
morning Baltimore you there yes I'm here
go ahead please yes sir I want to find
out not with with a rack did you go over
to Iraq did the government go over to
Iraq to services own needs as far as oil
well certainly oil was part of it the
Middle East has always been about oil
oil is power both the first president
Bush and people like Senator Luger and
others have warned that we don't want to
become dependent on countries who have a
lot of oil under their control the and
are antagonistic to the u.s. I mean I
don't know why it's even debatable one
of the oil industry foundations in New
York an impeccable pro oil industry
source said
for the invasion this war is not about
oil but after it's over it's all about
oil and of course now with 110 billion
barrels of proven reserves and Counting
the US oil companies are savoring the
kinds of concessions this whole
oil-for-food deal that the US wants to
take complete control on over with
Britain from the United Nations pursuant
to a UN resolution and you hear colin
powell say this oil is going to be in a
humanitarian trust fund for the Iraqi
people but you don't hear how many
deductions is going to be for expenses
and profits and and royalties etc and
how much is going to be left for the
Iraqi people when you're not appearing
on a TV program like this how are you
spending your days these days well in
several ways we have a local project
here that illuminates the abandonment of
our libraries in the United States
called the DC library Renaissance
project.org for people who are
interested the DC library system which
can be so great for kids and doing
something about thirty-seven percent
functional illiteracy rate in a district
Columbia is the worst in the country
it's ranked 51st it's decrepit it's
decayed mayor Williams has ignored it
we're also doing rallies all over the
country from Tampa to Portland Oregon
Portland Maine New Haven Austin Texas
Boston where we get dozens and dozens of
local citizen groups having tables in
the runways of these large arenas we
have like a citizen Jamboree people are
interested in having these kinds of
events or interested in mobilizing for a
strong democracy to solve so many of our
perceived and justices and problems in
this country can log in to info at
democracy rising or gets info at
democracy rising org and then thirdly
and quickly the corporate crime wave I
know it's off the front pages I'm son to
business pages but it's off the front
pages it's still going on the
settlements are anemic and slaps on the
wrist not one CEO according to lou dobbs
of CNN has ever gone to has been sent to
jail yet convicted and sent to jail in
these corporate crooker ease as we call
them crime into sweets
and trillions of dollars from millions
of Americans and their pension funds and
their jobs that should be a number one
priority for federal law and order and
expanding a number of federal cops on
the corporate be so we're trying to
mobilize people all over the country we
have a specific and a corporate reform
package all the way from dealing with
corporate executive compensation which
is the fuel for a lot of the inflated
profits and accounting shenanigans to
cracking down on corporate crime and
that website is citizen works org and
people get a free weekly electronic
newsletter bringing you up today
indicating what folks are doing all over
the country for State Attorney General's
security regulators as well as the
federal government in applying some law
and order so this not happen again by
people losing their entire pensions
losing their jobs look at the thousands
of people laid off by enron and worldcom
and that this is something that should
command the attention of law schools law
professors law students it's amazing you
know we used to have in our country
scandal and be followed by reform now
scandal at the SNL scandal are followed
by bigger scandals you know the the wall
street scandals and very little is being
done so again climb on board info at
democracy rising org 20 minutes left
with Ralph Nader Foley Alabama thanks
for hanging on high good morning mr.
Nader good morning you have very
interesting comments but there's one you
got wrong my friend go ahead Benjamin
Franklin's quotes yes it is quoted as a
man who relies on the security of
liberty shall have neither am I wrong am
i right well I'll give you the benefit
of the doubt most of the quotes of our
founding fathers tend to be paraphrased
because some of the language is a bit
archaic by today's standards you want to
repeat that again a man who relies on
the security of liberty shall have
neither well thank you very much for
that anything else one AD well it was
just totally different from the meaning
that you know what you use the mr. Nader
had quoted but I just wanted to throw
that in there
I don't think it's totally different I
think it's more precise go ahead let's
move on to London England hello hello
good morning mr. Nader good morning hi
you're talking about scandals that don't
reach the front pages of newspapers or
any of the new stations but they do
sometimes turn up in Great Britain and
some of your American journalists have
to get them reported here one of which
that I know of certainly is Katherine
Harris the secretary of state of Florida
hired a computer company for two million
dollars to purge the electoral rolls of
about 90,000 blacks and Hispanics mainly
who turned out to be Democrat voters
when they turned up in a 2000 election
to vote they had lost their right to
vote because they'd been designated as
felons illegally where do you read that
this was in The Guardian this is on BBC
newsnight Greg Palast is the journalist
who broke the story and couldn't get CBS
2 to actually follow it up because
actually I read it in the Washington
Post in New York Times at the time as
well that actually was fairly well
publicité was publicized in John Nichols
book Jews for Buchanan and pub and
mentioned by jeffrey toobin book too
close to call but I get your point a lot
of times we have to go to the British
press the independent the observer in
order to find out things in this country
that aren't very widely reported they
may be given a squib here and there but
they're not very widely reported
including our activities as a nation
abroad lawrenceville georgia good
morning i'm surprised how wrong mr.
Nader can be on so many different
subjects but the one that I'd like to
talk about is his idea that seventy
percent of Americans have been
bamboozled by the president regarding
Iraq's participation in September 11th
first of all the president never made
that statement second of all the numbers
that i read in my paper were about
thirty five percent of us americans were
bamboozled but I just wondering how you
expect to get elected president if you
think that seventy percent of Americans
are just so stupid that they don't don't
understand so seventy percent of the
Americans who supported George Bush
to either the New York Times or Wall
Street Journal I can't remember which
but even take take your figure that's
pretty substantial number mislead and I
beg to differ if you look at the weekly
complication compilations of President
Bush's statements you'll see that many
times he said the Saddam Hussein it was
in direct coordination or communication
with al-qaeda terrorists that they were
in Iraq when he was challenged on that
by his own intelligence advises he would
move into another linguistic mode by
saying that Saddam Hussein was allied
with al-qaida type terrorists no he said
it again again there's no mistake about
it that he wanted to convey that
impression obviously because he knew
that would increase substantially a
public support for the war but the
record is clear and I refer you to the
weekly compilation of every public
utterance by President Bush you can get
it by going to the Government Printing
Office and ordering a subscription here
is a fax mr. Nader what's your opinion
concerning the exporting of our
manufacturing and agricultural basis to
countries with virtually no regulations
of labor or safety and environmental
issues well that's an example of the
result of NAFTA and the World Trade
Organization professor emeritus Seymour
Melman at Columbia University address
that point that we are d industrializing
our economy in part because there are no
safety nuts overseas be companies can
close down plants lay off workers in
this country and go to Indonesia or
Bangladesh or India or Guangdong
Province in China using surf labor maybe
twenty cents an hour labor no
protections no benefits no environmental
rules bribe your way through to do
whatever you want and then ship the
products back to the United States
against companies and workers here who
are playing by the rules and Seymour
Melman by the way can be reached at the
unit at Columbia University he has an
excellent memorandum on this that he
will send people he made the point the
other day that in ll beams most recent
Christmas catalog ninety percent of all
the products listed in that catalog were
import
here's another one commits donator
please address the media consolidation
that is taking place in particular
Rupert Murdoch's purchase of the New
York Post fox TV UPN directv etc and the
FCC's inability to enforce preexisting
monopoly laws well I think if you ask
Senator John McCain for his opening
statement last Tuesday when he had a
hearing on media concentration he'll
list all the holdings of Rupert Murdoch
and they're unbelievable in terms of
their scope the diversity of radio TV
newspapers magazines cable and right now
according to professor Ben beg Dickian
of the University of California Berkeley
emeritus in his book media monopoly
we're down to about six gigantic media
conglomerates who own and control the
bulk of the audiences and the
subscribers and the readers in our
country and when he first wrote his book
about 18 years ago there are about 40 of
these companies so that's what's going
on and of course what happens is you
have fewer local reporters in Minot
North Dakota there's six commercial
radio stations they're all owned by
clear channel so you have fewer local
reporters more syndicated standardized
stuff by absentee button pushers for the
media and ninety percent of the Airways
which people owned by the way is
composed of entertainment and
advertising and the rest often with
exception of some few good programs like
60 minutes the rest are rapid weather
sports news weather sports news and of
course the inestimable c-span back to
the phone so Ralph Nader all gray
Michigan and we pronounce that right
print Michigan yes you pronounced it
right I voted for Nader and does he
think the Green Party is a viable
political art alternative or do we need
a completely new political movement to
replace the Democratic Party well we
need certainly a new political parties
the Green Party I think concentrating on
local and state office can begin to win
right away they won about twenty
twenty-five percent of the local seats
they contested in the years 2001 and
2002 and so they you build a party
the grassroots there's there are two and
a half million elected offices in the
united states so there's a lot of
opportunity a lot of them are one party
districts the incumbent isn't challenged
by the other major party so it's a great
opportunity for the Greens to run Boards
of Education City Council Development
Authority I always say to the greens run
run run because the more who run the
more activity that will be on behalf of
the Green Party what does the Green
Party stand for define it for us well it
stands for obviously its image as it
stands for sustainable economies
worldwide environmental health and
safety preservation of our resources
that means more recycling more solar
energy more organic agriculture for
example substitution of petrochemicals
or with say industrial hemp and other
recyclable and degradable products it
also stands for living wage strong labor
laws protecting workers repeal of
taft-hartley stands for Clean Elections
public funding of public elections the
nadir leduc ticket did not take any PAC
money no corporate money in the year
2000 we we set try to set a model an
example for other parties it also as
opposed to corporate welfare and all
these subsidies going into as athletic
stadiums while schools and Clinics
crumble and City after City for lack of
repair in many ways it stands for a
stronger democracy where corporate
corporate sovereignty is subjugated to
the sovereignty of the people you said
earlier it's too early to tell whether
you'll run again in two thousand or is
there a moment or a phrase or an issue
or something that's going to say now I'm
going to decide well I want to see what
the Democrats are willing to support
this time and not just verbally but in
terms of their campaigning give them
another another chance to show whether
they represent the people or represent
the corporate packs and in the
commercial interests that now have their
hooks into them through the Democratic
Leadership Council and what we call the
corporate Democrats San Diego hello hi
good morning well I'd like to ask Ralph
what he would have done if he had been
elected the president in in two thousand
in response to
911 as well as a proliferation of the
weapons of mass destruction I personally
believe that the president and they may
still be found but I have full
confidence that the president thought
and again I may still be found but I
think he actually thought that the
Saddam Hussein which we will have to
agree as a menace to the to that area of
not the world bottom line anyway Ralph
is what would you have done in response
to 911 as well as what the president's
trying to do regarding some of the other
hot spots in the world where we've got
pelipper a proliferation of masters of
weapons of mass destruction Thank You
Ralph Nader by the way the Green Party
also very strong on civil liberties and
civil rights I don't want to neglect
that and a criminal justice system
worthy of the name the caller raises an
interesting question I think if you talk
to arms control specialists who are not
obsessed with Saddam Hussein who if he
was a threat to any of his neighbors and
indicated that would have been
obliterated by Israel Turkey and Iran
with whom he is he had hostile relations
is this the number one nuclear
proliferation problem in your world
today is the proliferation of the
weapons in the former Soviet Union the
scientists many of them are unemployed
they may be tempted to work for some
foreign interests there's huge caches of
chemical biological warfare nuclear
radioactive materials our country's only
spending a hundred million dollars
trying to deal with that problem in
Russia and trying to retain the
scientists are not tempted to go to find
other clients who are violent minded now
we're going to spend a hundred billion
dollars on Iraq and and the Russia still
has a missiles aimed at us we have
missiles aimed at Russia it's a second
problem in nuclear proliferation is
accidental release because a lot of
these are computer based and there's
very little attention paid for that but
a hundred billion dollars
for a weakened dictatorship in Iraq
surrounded by much more powerful hostile
enemies in the region itself so you know
we've got our priorities all screwed up
after 911 what we should have done that
mr. Bush didn't do because he toppled
the Taliban but now 99% of Afghanistan
is under the control of violent warring
warlords who are pillaging and
plundering that country hardly a hardly
qualifies not being a security risk to
the United States already attacking our
troops some of the Taliban are
regrouping but we should have moved
through a multilateral force with
commandos spies and bribes to deal with
this criminal gang instead what we did
was we toppled a regime and replaced it
with chaos with total anarchy and now
are abandoning our man in Kabul and not
even completing a road I mean we having
completed a road from Kabul to Kandahar
in terms of repairing it even though
President Bush said that their country
is going to be rebuilt with us help so
this business of hitting and running a
bombing and cutting out away does not
give us much credibility in the world
we've got the strength in the United
Nations here in many ways we created the
United Nations more than any other
country in the world 1945 and we we have
an administration that has been carping
ridiculing weakening the United Nations
quite apartment not paying its full dues
on time what do you make of this
so-called roadmap for peace in the
Middle East Israel and Palestinians well
we'll see you know it seems to me if our
country wants peace between Israelis and
Palestinians it will flat out support a
very significant peace movement in
Israel which has been going on for many
years at times they filled squares in
Tel Aviv with a hundred thousand
demonstrators I mean you want peace in
the Middle East you don't deal with
extremists you don't deal with
militarists as Colin Powell said there's
no military solution to this problem you
deal with the pullet with the peace
movement which is composed of members of
the Israeli Knesset former attorney
generals ministers of Justice
business leaders I mean it's a
remarkably broad-based effort but it
never gets much support from the US
government chalfont Pennsylvania thanks
for waiting you're on with Ralph Nader
thank you an honor to speak to mr. Nader
yes sir I I'd like to ask your opinion
on the suite unethical policies of the
Bush administration with regards to
halliburton back on other companies that
are being allowed to rebuild Iraq
without any opposing bids or any input
from any other cab companies and why the
media hasn't been more active on this
story well the media has been active
certainly newspapers I've read have
reported it although having trouble
keeping up to date because they don't
have access to the contracts between mr.
Bush former Halliburton CEO Dick Cheney
and Halliburton and its subsidiaries
those contracts must be made public if
there's any national security part of it
it can be redacted they must be made
public mitch Daniels the head of the
budget bureau for President Bush favors
putting all government contracts above a
certain dollar level online contracts of
the Department of Interior with the
resources companies coal oil gas
Pentagon contracts with Lockheed Martin
all these contracts should be online so
the American people students scholars
press can have ready access and for
example you point out that these were
single source contracts and you're right
there was no competitive bidding and the
argument that there's no other company
that can do this work is nonsense there
are other companies that have come to
the forefront it's just the buddy system
between houston texas in washington that
is still at work shamelessly even though
members of congress like congressman
henry waxman has exposed this by the way
are the details on all of this
Halliburton contracts contact
congressman henry waxman's office or his
website and you'll see the letters back
and forth that he's had with the bush
administration on this walnut creek
california yes it sure is the great
american democracy and somebody like me
can have voice over here i really would
like to see it as a viable candidate
mr. Nader but what I see from here most
of the time is a criticism not a viable
solution and alternative and that's why
probably or the marginal candidate here
you really need to come up with better
more viable understandable solutions
other than just criticizing and when
they ask you a question regarding what
should have been done you always come
back with our United Nations United
Nations is a 181 member most of
dictatorship or armed brutal regimes
club it's not an american-style
democracy you can compare with so you
really need to come up with viable
solutions rather than just criticize
well if you look if you read the book
crashing particle seats full of
solutions solution to our energy problem
is rigorous energy efficiency in great
detail the technologies are available as
many people have pointed out the the key
energy efficiency groups in this city
and in Colorado and Berkeley have
pointed that out the solutions are on
the ground they're working in number of
buildings and homes and engines and so
forth so the solutions are are all there
except that you have to deal with the
criticisms because the criticisms often
offend large corporations and
corporations advertising the criticism
don't get as much air time I must say
that living wage is certainly a solution
why can't the minimum wage be indexed to
its purchasing power of 1968 when the
economy was only half as large per
capita production as it is today
universal health care Canada has it
gives people their full choice of doctor
and hospital which tens of millions of
Americans don't have in this country
does it on much less percent of its
gross national product and what we're
already spending clean elections there
are all kinds of drafted legislation
there I think you may be part of the
public that is often attracted to the
criticisms and reacts the way you did
but let me tell you we're full of
solutions just check citizen org health
research group Congress
watch Czech citizen works org check
essential org there is no end to the
solutions that citizen groups are
proposing they're not pie in the sky
solutions but unless you have legitimate
political movements that have a chance
to go under presidential debates and get
on the media have a chance to get on the
ballot and overcome those horrendous
ballot access problems like in North
Carolina you're not going to hear about
these solutions and you're going to
react the way you just did with your
question as far as the United Nations
concerned most of these countries are
under US influence to begin with the
General Assembly doesn't make the policy
in terms of post 9-11 and Iraq it's the
Security Council we have the veto on the
Security Council and maybe if we were a
little more multilateral instead of
unilateral something most Americans
according to the polls prefer that we'd
be more multilateral with other nations
and other allies we could have even
greater support than we already have
historically by the Security Council
it's hard to find a substitute for
United Nations we can make it week we
can divide it we can also lead it oh
thanks to Ralph Nader for joining us the
Sunday appreciate your time thank you
very much thanks for c-span again and I
would say thanks to everybody who called
in in this segment we'll be back at
seven o'clock